Vanity Fair spoke to two of the movie's
casting directors Lucy Bevin and Alison
Jones as it turns out we missed out on
three potential Kens Bowen Yang Dan Levy
and Ben Platt all wanted to play Ken's
butts couldn't make it work due to
covid-19 restrictions in place during
filming what do I have to do you have to
go to the real world while Bobby was in
production the entire cast had to commit
to staying in London for the entirety of
the shoot due to strict covid-19
protocols and yang Levy and platter
couldn't make the commitment for a
variety of reasons it's easy enough to
guess why Yang is a cast member on
Saturday Night Live Dan Levy just
briefly worked on the idol and Platt is
currently starring in parade on Broadway
as well as a new film Theater Camp still
the casting directors said that those
actors were quite upset that they
couldn't make it work Jones told Vanity
Fair they were I'm not kidding I'm
really bummed they couldn't do it